you know how many universities are
teaching classes to become an
entrepreneur today hundreds do you know
why people are starting to figured out
they're starting to figured out you know
who still what generation is really
figuring it out it's so interesting to
me
it's boomers do you know why boomers are
figuring it out because they have the
most experience in the workforce and
they know it doesn't work anymore and
Millennials and Gen Xers are not asking
anything questioning anything they're
just doing what boomers did they're
going to getting a job they're not
realizing the original reason why
nine-to-five job was created do you know
originally you know this nine-to-five is
only a two-year period thing anyone
knows us like nine-to-five has not been
on for thousands of years it's only 80
years old do you know why we agreed to
work 9:00 to 5:00
why 9:00 to 5:00 do you know why we
agreed to work that 9:00 to 5:00 do you
know why daylight hours and you know who
invented 9:00 to 5:00 by what was the
company that invented 9:00 to 5:00 you
should know it you know it Ford Motor
Company at that time Ford was a
godfather of companies in Detroit
whatever they did everybody else did so
here's how was hey Vicky I would like to
have you give 30 years of your life to
my company Ford Motor Company and Vicky
says what she goes like this and she
says what your question would be what
what do I get for giving you 30 years
and I said I'm sorry I'm Ford she says
I'm sorry what am I gonna get for my 30
years I guess that's a fair question
okay you give me 30 years of your life
staying with me at the company I'm gonna
give you a 30 or pension plan wait a
minute so I work for you 30 years then
you gonna give me my income I am fair
deal boom we shake hands good
negotiation